would you have ever thought that you
would have been with somebody like me no
never ever in my life I never thought
you people existed at that was just
which what do you would you meet you be
loved
what do you mean leave me by that funny
attractive okay okay that's not what she
thought at all no I feel like your ideal
version of a guy was actually the
complete opposite of me it was somebody
you remember when we first started going
on I remember you used to tell me about
I don't know if it was a slight to me
but you could always mention you know in
when I was in Taiwan these guys they
would always open the doors for me
rollin they would just when it when it
would rain they would take off their
check and shield me for these guys guys
who love to watch Korean dramas and be
that main character cuz that's the guy I
thought who was that guy in Taiwan that
you were talking about which one the one
that you said was like super sweet you
had a big crush on him but nothing ever
happened oh yeah he who was he i I don't
know what did he do I don't remember but
I remember you told me he wrote you a
letter or something before you left or
oh no that was that was in college yeah
that was not in Taiwan nothing what was
that one that which one that I want the
college guy the college guy oh we're
just really good friends and you know I
was really comfortable with him was like
my girlfriend he was like oh my god yeah
that's such a painful thing to hear as a
guy when a guy hears that the girl that
he really really likes that he's just
infatuated with goes yeah you're like
one of my girlfriend's spear to the
hardest well he didn't say anything he
was just like you know one of the
girlfriends we always hung out together
and I was really comfortable with him
and he was really comfortable with me as
well I guess but there was no hints of
anything like there was no moves what do
you mean there was nothing no if there
was a sign and I would have been like
uh-oh you know and maybe something we
would have talked about her something
but then it was until the last minute
after we graduated where I got this
present and a letter and it was it was a
really sweet letter what did the letter
say it was like a poem what
with a sweet [ __ ] move man poem this
was almost 10 years ago so I don't
remember I just remember it was really
sweet and I was like uh-oh what was the
poem about was it about how beautiful
you are was oh my god it was a it was a
song I must say your eyes are like a
glitters he did not have that kind of
accident it's an enduring message saying
matters of that something like this I
remember there was sunshine and sunshine
what else did he say about you I don't
know but you just you didn't fall for
that why not he's weren't attracted to
him no I didn't see him that way and
that was the last time I saw him because
we just disappeared off the face of the
earth well we left after college we went
back home and we don't live in the same
area so what well I mean if you guys
were such good friends how come you guys
didn't continue the friendship after
that would he just feel too embarrassed
or what no I mean I still kept in touch
with him but he he on the other hand
didn't and I figured because his heart
was broken I mean I don't know did I
break his heart
maybe he must have liked you for a while
then I think so because how long were
you guys friends yeah he probably liked
you for two years and he finally
mustered up enough courage to finally
talk to you about his feelings the last
day before we leave it's like well it
was going to happen
yeah well I've known a couple of guys
who did that just because they feel like
this is my last chance but they don't
really think about what happens if that
person says no right so in their mind
they've already done so much work to
lead up to the yes that the no is not
even a possibility so when they hear the
no they're not prepared for their whole
world comes crashing down like I bet you
it feels like they're in a cave right
and they see this exit this bright light
and as they're walking towards it
suddenly some it's you with that with
that cartoon detonator with the dynamite
and in school
or maybe he just knew that it wasn't
gonna work out he just had to let it out
somehow you know yeah I'm probably not
though cuz he wrote you a poem and it
wasn't about and there wasn't him saying
like in the poem it I'm pretty sure
didn't end with and if you say no I'll
still love you forever
my little petunia no it was I'm putting
my heart on the line and if you crush it
I'm gonna die and disappear from the
face of this verse he didn't ask me if I
was a yes or no though of course cuz he
little [ __ ] that's why I know ye yeah
but that was not the Taiwan guy Sam oh
wait how did we come around there the
Taiwan guy was I just remembered you
talked about him like he was the he was
like the epitome of the nice of a
gentleman he was he was he was such a
gentleman he was always taking care of
me
you know I mean it but he liked you too
though right I don't know to be honest I
don't know I don't think so maybe I'm
not sure because he was he was dating
someone Oh was he
hmm but it was weird because that girl
was taking care of me very well too and
I didn't know this was like a Taiwanese
thing or I don't know oh so you like the
guy with up with a girl that you knew no
I didn't know her she was new in the
group so we hung out and then later on
found that he was dating someone and
then he she came around to attend this
event and she was taking so many photos
of us no joke five hundred plus 500 plus
I get this huge message and like who why
is she taking photos of you guys she was
just thinking photos of the event and us
and everything but specifically me and I
was weird maybe she was doing research
about the girl that's trying to take her
man away she beta less what would have
happened if you got if you if you got
together with that guy um I probably
would have stayed there
you probably stayed there longer yeah I
probably would have stayed maybe I don't
know because my intention wasn't to stay
there forever but you know it didn't
happen for a reason
and I came back home a lot sooner than I
expected
did for a reason and you know I feel
like your perception of a what a
relationship was or what a guy was was
really skewed when I first met you
like I didn't meet anyone like you
before that's why it was always that
kind of guy that kind of those kind of
guys were always around me bunch of
[ __ ]
sweet sweet guys remember quote of your
day was what would Dan do no that's
different see for you biz because like
when I first met you um like you had a
your perception of a guy was very
interesting I feel like it was highly
influenced dude - all those Disney
movies that you watched but I really do
feel that way or Korean dramas I was
like Korean dramas and these guys do not
exist
Oh like you know you know what I mean a
lot of people are very good at putting
up a front a lot of people and you know
this - so Mary Hill actually told me the
story back in the day or her mom tried
to set her up with this guy oh yeah
right and this story was so interesting
because it was very indicative of a lot
of these guys that I saw at church so in
the Korean culture or I guess I just
feel like anything any type of culture
anyways or conservative culture exactly
so that people are very good at putting
up front so especially in a church
setting if you went to a Korean Church
all these kids in front of the parents
would be the sweetest angels you've ever
met in your life right so these dudes
they would inside very well so like
greet parents I know you know whatever
do all that other crap and so and their
parents would talk up their children as
well because they're not gonna talk [ __ ]
about their kids they're gonna say my
son Peter Kim he's going to be a doctor
he's studying really hard he's really
handsome and they tried to and so he
should kill they try to they try to
match up their kids with other kids and
so Muriel's mom consistently try to put
muriel with one of these korean kids
so these korean dudes albeit when you
first meet them are very likeable in the
sense of if you look at their stats yeah
they have everything that you want out
of a future son-in-law but what happens
is when they're not in front of their
parents their true colors show mm-hmm so
what what happened when you went on a
game with this guy this this guy that
your mom set you up with so
apparently it's it's through my aunt
actually oh yeah she introduced this guy
to my mom saying that you know he is a
praise band lead he's very dedicated to
church he's a really sweet guy and you
know he got everything else I don't know
he has like a great job whatever and
it'll be perfect for her Muriel and what
my mom's like okay let's set them up so
the guy who was supposed to pick me up
at my place
he did his car he brought his I don't
know Toyota or Infiniti car I go inside
there and the first thing I smell is
cigarette
really bad cigarette stain smell and I
hate that smell mmm-hmm I hate it so
much and it's like this car that was
about to break down and he was like oh
sorry I'm like 30 minutes late blah blah
blah I was like whatever this is already
going down there for me he's like so
let's go to let's go to know like a bar
or something and there's no bar near my
hometown so I was asking him a bar he's
like oh there's this place called good
times good times is this janky Korean
bar that's usually for high school kids
because people can't you know if you're
under it or is it 21 yeah under 21 you
can't go to bar so they allow high
school kids to go inside here yeah it's
no longer there I think I think for good
reason
yeah but he likes going there so he
asked me to go there and I was my first
time ever going to that place I hate
that place and we sit down and the first
thing he does he says I'm gonna get out
my cigarette and let's drink and I was
so confused cuz my aunt told me my mom
told me that oh this is like this really
sweet you know Christian guy who's
apparently and supposed to be an angel
and straight up he tells me he's like
you know I bet you're on told me that
I'm an angel but really I'm not unlike
this oh he's trying to be mr. cool guy
and let me tell you something baby you
want all these other people out here
saying that I'm like this goody
two-shoes but I smoke cigarettes
he wasn't oppa oh he was one of those
dudes yep I had like that I was like
this is so okay as like two things I
hate is that you first of all smoke I
hate that smell and second you're trying
to be this cool
that I hate yeah it's like I like the
cool but who takes me you know on a hike
or whatever but not cigarette and sold
you I hate that yeah and so obviously
you didn't know that and I was just
playing on with him I was like fine
whatever you know help you you know pay
for my lunch it was any time to it
doesn't help that drinking during the
daytime what the [ __ ] yeah he was just
he was like that this is what I do I
know I'm all angel at church but really
like I also he was he was actually
saying that to impress you so he was
trying to say that to get you to like I
was like yo I know like I'm actually a
bad boy sometimes I get b-minus is on my
test you know sometimes I even dare to
get a c-plus and I'm like oh ma I don't
care I don't know to be honest at that
time I was like this is not not the type
of guy I want a date but for my on and
my mom say guys I got I'll just have
like a decent lunch with him and then
bounce and so we did that went back home
and I told my mom was like I don't like
this guy mm-hmm actually I don't think I
even mentioned it to her because I
didn't want her to bug me about it and I
feel bad for my on because they don't
know who what kind of guy he is
clearly and I didn't want to ruin that
for people it's like it's none of my
business you know so later on he did
call me back he's like hey let's hang
out again like I guess he liked me so he
kept calling and calling and I got to
the point where I was like I don't want
to hang out with you and he told my aunt
and my aunt told my mom and my mom
called me back angry she was so mad that
I would not go out with them again
because she was like that's the perfect
kid yeah she said this guy is super
sweet and nice and he's an angel and
he's a good Christian guy why wouldn't
you go out with him again
and I I was so mad at my mom because she
wouldn't listen to me I was like mom I
don't like this guy he's not my type can
you please leave me alone how come you
didn't tell her about the whole
cigarettes and him getting drunk during
the daytime yeah I first I didn't and
then I told her I was like mom you want
to know why I don't like this guy and I
told her the reasons mm-hmm she did not
believe me oh really
she thought I was lying to her have you
talked to her did you tell her about
this recently like yeah just talk to her
about it now and tell her about it
Oh a couple years ago it was brought up
and I told my moms like do you remember
that time my mom mom that you almost
kicked me out because of that guy
she almost kicked me out of the house
because she thought I was lying to her
house because you know creepy lives so
extreme I think she found out later on
that I was telling the truth because she
said right my job I was like good and
then I told her I was after that you
never asked me to go on a good thing
again and she said yes she did not fight
back she's like my job my job so I was
really glad because she probably felt
really guilty you know oh I feel so
betrayed
of course because it sucks as a kid when
you go through something that was a
terrible experience right and then I
think this old man who's so dark how old
was he he was in his late 20s I was in
my early 20s okay like so let's just
turn to anyone I'd be like a eight year
difference yeah and he looks so dark and
like you know those crows yeah and see
that's the thing too I think like I like
just to go back to what I was saying it
sucks when in that case two for you
anyways you were actually shielding your
mom from this thing because you wanted
to save her from the embarrassment yeah
and then even after you did something
like that and you're doing it from the
goodness of your heart and you finally
confided in her about this horrible
experience that you had she took the
side of the other guy without taking
your side and you're not her yeah and
that that probably hurt you a lot yeah
and it happens a lot I feel like an
agent families just because sometimes
it's it's not even about you know I
should take the side of my child it's
more like I don't want to look dumb so I
think like that's the instant reaction
is making a hyper defensive you know we
do that too I do it too sometimes even
in our relationships and I was mentioned
this before on a JK news episode where
I'm not sure if you notice this isn't
pretty sure you do there are times when
I'm so damn wrong I will never say that
I'm wrong but like a guilty dog I just
want look